like most roguelites return fun is found
in developing skills through failure
with each run
teaching you something new that you can
use for the next one
if you're finding the opening hours
especially challenging here are 11 tips
that will help you get up to speed
with your eternal's pace and explain
some of its more obscure mechanics to
save you some time
[Music]
don't stop moving house marquee is
departing from its traditional
2d arcade shooter roots with returnal
but that doesn't mean it hasn't brought
with it
the same fundamental gameplay pillars
one of those is the bombardment of
projectiles and
enemies you'll have to deal with making
any time you remain stationary
progressively more dangerous returns
combat arenas are designed to feel
cramped
purposefully but each one offers nooks
and crannies for you to exploit
allowing you to create space and
distance from foes
better yet consistently moving around
forces enemies to break formation
and find different ways to get to you
creating better chances for you to pick
them off individually
as your arsenal of gadgets grows your
ability to move around a space expands
too
the grappling hook which you only
unlocked a few hours in is a great
example of this
letting you string together life-saving
swings and dexterous dodges
to get out of even the hairiest
situations but when push comes to shove
making sure you're comfortable with the
ridiculous speed of celine's
sprint will go a long way toward
ensuring your survival
as long as you're moving as much as
you're shooting you'll be fine
aiming down sights has benefits with a
focus on movement it might seem
redundant for eternal even to include
an option to aim down the sights of your
weapon it slows you down and forces you
to be precise
at the expense of a more narrow field of
view
that could mean missing some incoming
projectiles
it's tempting then to just never use ads
and rely on the accuracy of hit fire but
then you'll be missing out on exploiting
weak spots on enemies
this is especially important for both
boss-like enemies
each of which generally features a weak
point that can only be seen when aiming
down the sights
it also helps you focus your fire on
these points which can be crucial for
both slow firing weapons
and ones with small magazine sizes pay
attention to your active reload
like gears of war returner features an
active reload system that can help you
reload your weapons
faster with the right timing each weapon
and variation features its own timing
and active reload window
which can be a bit confusing to get into
a rhythm with at first
but your perseverance will be rewarded
as in a chaotic fight
the difference between life and death
can be the second or two wasted
on a missed timed or missed active
reload especially
with weapons that need to be reloaded
with every shot
focus on the bar in your crosshair and
adjust to the dynamic
timing window with every new weapon you
pick up
you will be rewarded for it high tier
weapons aren't always the best choice
weapons you find in returnal are
governed by weapon proficiency
a bar you gradually fill up during each
run that determines the tier of weapons
you'll find
it might be tempting to just focus on
the overall weapon level and swap for
anything higher than what you have
but as runs start becoming longer and
enemies introduce
more complex attack patterns having a
weapon that you're comfortable with
is often more deadly than one with a
higher level
avoid damage as much as possible this
might seem like a no-brainer for a
shooter
getting hit less means less death so
of course you're going to avoid it thing
is
shooters make us accustomed to taking
some hits to deal out a few
often with systems that lean towards
rewarding you
even if you're careless return isn't
like that at all and that's evident
in its adrenaline mechanic your
adrenaline multiplier increases with
every few enemies you kill without
taking damage
going up to a maximum level of 5. each
level comes with its own perks such as
the ability to detect enemies through
walls a more powerful melee attack and
even more currency rewards on kills
take damage however and that gets reset
down to zero
it's worth prioritizing your adrenaline
meter since there are upgrades that give
you added benefits
from adrenaline such as healing
dash into danger not away from it one of
the skills you start with
is an incredibly useful dash that you
can pull off pretty much
anywhere but unlike many action games
free eternal expects you to use it to go
towards projectiles
not necessarily away from them while
dashing you are invincible to attacks
letting you use it to bypass a wall of
projectiles while
also closing the gap to an enemy for a
devastating melee kill
your dodge is also used for some light
puzzle solving as many optional rooms
will be brimming
with lasers and other hazards that you
will need to deftly dodge through to
escape
things change later in the run where
certain attacks denoted by
their purple color will not allow you to
dash through them
safely this can be slightly jarring
after hours of muscle memory telling you
that it's totally doable but just be
warned of the sudden shift
don't forget your powerful melee
speaking of melee once you've managed to
get far enough into eternal's first
biome you'll be rewarded with a
permanent melee attack
which you should incorporate into your
attacks as much
as you can not only does it just look
phenomenal
when you slice an enemy just right but
your melee is consistently
one of the most powerful attacks in the
game
most enemies outside of bosses will die
with one slash
if at half or less health as you pump up
your adrenaline level your melee will
become even more
powerful letting you clear whole groups
of enemies at a time
it can be easy to forget about when
you're more preoccupied with returning
projectiles at enemies but ignoring
melee will make return
action harder to cope with as it becomes
more frantic
always search for health and resin one
mechanic returner doesn't immediately
make clear
is the intrinsic link between health
pickups and your ability to increase
your total health pool
health pickups differ between resin and
vials the former contributes to a bar
aside your health
that when filled will increase your
total slightly
while the latter simply heals any
missing health
what isn't explained is that if you're
at full health all vials on the map
act like resin meaning they contribute
to growing your health total too
you can sprint through new combat arenas
trying to gather all these pickups
before potentially taking damage to
enemies but that also leaves you with
nothing to heal up with
after a battle conversely you can ignore
them until after a fight
but you could find yourself getting
later and later into a run without an
adequate health total
to draw from either way it's good to
remember not to ignore these pickups
entirely
even if you're fully topped up don't use
items immediately as you find them on
that note though
don't feel compelled to make these
decisions as they are presented to you
which goes double for any items
fabrication stations
and more you find in each biome returnal
has each of its biomes littered with
fast travel points encouraging you to go
back to areas you might have left items
in to reap their rewards later
for example consumables you had no space
for
can still be picked up well after you've
left the room you found them in
return's great map makes it easy to
recall where points of interest
are so don't get too caught up in
forward progression and
instead take a moment to take stock back
track a little and ensure
you have everything possible before
moving on
skipping biomes is totally viable once
you unlock a new biome it can be
deflating to die early on into it and be
greeted with the sting of a restarting
your run
the good news is that once unlocked the
path to a new biome is usually presented
early into a new run
letting you skip right to it each biome
also features a weapon proficiency
upgrade at the start to bring you right
up to what is required for the enemies
ahead of you
but you'll still need to find a weapon
on that level to be fully
up to speed that said farming is
important too
so while it might be tempting to
immediately jump back to where you've
died the reality is
that you're making things more difficult
for yourself that way
each death resets you basically back to
zero with only your total inventory
slots for consumables
staying intact that means suit upgrades
total health parasites all get reset
which can make
instant jumps and biomes a daunting
prospect
there's value in getting familiar with
the starting biome and using your
refined skills to upgrade as much as
possible
without taking damage and only then
jumping back to where you last died
better still you don't need to fight
each biomes boss again
but learning how to dispatch them
quickly comes with its own rewards too
we hope these beginner tips help you out
on your journey
if you have any tips we invite you to
share them in the comments thanks for
watching
see you later
[Music]
you